but London is a unique place where Finn
and tech come to meet in a way that
hasn't happened anywhere else so when we
were starting transferwise six years ago
we chose to do it in London because it
made sense great entrepreneurial place
you know the government that supports it
or back in the days the government it
supported entrepreneurship plenty of
talent a fantastic regulator so that's
kind of what has made London safe in the
capital of the world
what we don't know is what's going to
happen now what do you think will happen
what are you planning for because you've
got a financial power sourcing and B
movement of labour I guess though is
your - because there are two sort of two
things which mattered to us and you know
talent which matters to us most and
talent is really the lifeblood of any
fast-growing company so if you don't
have access to talent or if talent
doesn't want to come to where you are
then you're in trouble and you know we
have to see what common of talent you
know it's you know if if we try to cut
down and talent the drastically that's
going to be really bad for growing
businesses for growing tech businesses
in London the other one is past pouring
and I think we've kind of all given up
on passport in you know as pure business
contingency we are looking at where do
we establish our European headquarters
and we need to be done with it in two
years time you have 120 employees here
there must be an option which is we
don't need to be in London anymore we
could just move the whole thing to
Europe why would you do that we have a
fantastic business in the UK we 10% of
people who make international transfers
in UK use transferwise so you know it's
our biggest market and actually for the
reasons of serving this market well we
will always a presence in UK we're
headquartered here I think the trouble
it's not worth the trouble of moving you
know with we will need a European
headquarters for primarily for
regulatory reasons to get passport in
from Zaire but the moving our
headquarters doesn't doesn't make sense
what if there was another one of you
starting up another new clever FinTech
company right now
you chose to set up here in the UK with
the new you be coming to London or would
it be too much hard work it would be a
very tough choice to make and I think
there are very two days there are little
reasons to choose London if I was
starting up today it's quite likely I
would not do it in London you were the
first employee at Skype which is now
owned by Microsoft I wonder whether you
think there is a danger that all clever
ideas get sniped get snapped up by some
huge behemoth and we'll end up with a
with a world where a small number of
software giants will own everything it's
a it's a great thing to ponder about and
if we do if we do look at it you know I
think there are reasons to think this
way Microsoft has been ruling the world
for a long times and googles and
Facebooks and Amazon's or Apple but I so
I think inevitable in every industry we
see consolidation but we also see there
is a useful lifespan for most of these
companies so whereas things might be
consolidating to the previously
mentioned companies today I think over
time there's going to be new ones who
will disrupt these so I wouldn't worry
too much about it today and it begs the
question what's a useful lifespan of
your company at what point will somebody
make an offer for you that'll be too
good to refuse do you think I think
we're still just getting started we're
transferring more than a billion pounds
a month today you know I see that there
are trillions of pounds which move every
year and if and for us it's a beginning
so you know why what why would we sell
today when we can actually build a
company which changes the way finance
finance works